le pis de mon voisin est un cube le bébé
dès 6 heures du matin il se met à crier
à café dans ces malades souffrent et
sont hs a fait
son père joue du trombone dans une boîte
de nuit sa mère du saxophone et la
sereine et partie il n'y a plus personne
pour s'occuper d'outils qui s'ennuient
toute la journée ils n'arrêtent pas
crier chantelle boogie woogie en
réclamant son lait son père décourager
me crie j'en étais wet whisky
si bien que vers midi le gars c'est
tellement dès que debout sur son lit il
se met à danser et quand je l'entends
mur l'essai qui vient de tomber sont
blanches et
aussi par charité je suis allé chercher
en batch et le crémier une grande
bouteille de lait mais quand je les
portais à ce sacré vb une meuf
au début je me suis dit il y en a pour
quelques jours mais chaque jour ce répit
ya de quoi devenir fou surtout depuis
lundi on a payé aux petits
et
puis quand baradar devint vite d'une
fille chez moi que le cas plein d'espoir
je la prends dans mes pas en lui disant
touba cheryl embrassez-moi adore la
vie hier j'ai rencontré le père dans
l'escalier qui m'a dit tout heureux
j'avais me remarier avec mon cher
monsieur une femme iv 3d b3 et
b3 bébé 3 mai